[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to another
youtube exclusive video now a couple of
months ago i did a couple of videos
where i
uh solved exercises on chess.com of
various difficulty levels i did a
beginner one i did a master one
and those videos were really popular
people were asking for more uh and so
i've listened and so i want to make
another video where i i solve you know
right about five to ten uh intermediate
level
chess exercises
and uh as in the previous videos i'll
talk uh in a lot of detail through my
solution and through my process of
thinking
and and hopefully give you as many
insights as possible that can be applied
when you're solving exercises and
ultimately why do you even solve
exercises so that you can find these
tactics over the board
uh so without further ado let's let's
jump in okay
so we have here our first exercise with
black to play and i've set the the
rating range on chess.com to be 1800 to
2200 so right about intermediate puzzles
all right so what's going on here well
first thing that i see okay so it seems
like material is now black is down upon
this white has
sort of a four on three going here but
that's not very significant
um
and white's just played g4
which attacks the bishop so anytime a
pawn is pushed i think a lot of people
forget that
trust.com exercises give you the
previous move and that can act as a
pretty big hint right so anytime a pawn
is pushed there is going to be other
pawns there's going to be squares that
are weakened and so the first thing that
i see is this f3 pawn which uh which has
been left alone
and and so it's worth asking uh what
happens if we take that pawn with the
knight
well we take that pawn with the knight
we attack white's queen and if white's
queen moves then everything is easy
knight takes f3 let's say queen f2 or we
can just take that
knight with our bishop and
simultaneously defend the knight that's
going to land on f3
but if we look carefully after knight
takes f3 white also has the move g takes
f5 and that's quite a bit more testing
because
white counter attacks black's queen
and that leads to a situation where both
of the queens are hanging and i talk
about the situation a lot in my lessons
whenever both queens are hanging the
first thing that you should look for is
whether you can move your queen away
with check
uh and that should be perfectly logical
assuming your opponent has to defend
against the check and is not able to
cover that check with his own queen and
evade the attack then you're gonna be
able to take his queen on the next move
so let's look for any such checks knight
takes f3 gf well we can't check on g5
because white's knight controls that
square but we can step aside to h6
and what's very important about that is
that white cannot block with the queen i
mean he can but both e3 and d2 are
protected by black's queen and knight
respectively so i think we can go ahead
and take
and the crucial move here is queen h6
check
and if you don't see a check the second
thing you should look for is a desperado
sacrifice and i've talked about that in
in previous videos as well where you
essentially give up your queen for as
much material as you can
uh and and then take your opponent's
quick
simple enough
all right
so what's happening
what's happening here
um
okay well
first thing that i see is that both
kings are on the back rank and both
sides have a huge back rank weakness
white is threatening checkmate in one
and if we give a check on a1 white's
gonna cover with the knight so
this isn't just a made in one problem
the other thing that i see is that our
knight is hanging so there's quite a bit
going on even though there's not a lot
of pieces on the board um
so how would i even approach this
position well
you know
i would start by just
surveying and kind of understanding
uh potential tactical ideas that you
could apply and then putting together a
sequence that will involve defending
against the back rank made and then
perhaps exploiting our
ability to deliver a background check so
one thing that i notice here is that you
know
some positions you can give knight take
92 check i mean obviously not here
because white just takes that
but if white's queen is warded away from
g4 this check could be quite scary
because it could potentially send the
king back to h1
and if you if you think about that then
queen a1 is going to be made because
white can't really cover with the knight
now let's understand the order of
operations preferably we want to give
this check
when white already has a knight on f1
right because then
the king will not be able to move to f1
so it seems to make sense to start with
queen a1 check
that forces knight f1
now what we need to do is simultaneously
defend against the backrank mate and get
the queen off of g4 notice that r knight
is defended after queen a1 so we don't
have to worry about that do i see a way
to do that
okay well h5 comes to mind
but then the queen can just take on h5
and it's still defending e2 what about
f5 that seems like a better move f5
forces queen h5 so this is queen a1
check knight f1 f5 the queen has to keep
contact with the square queen h5 is
forced and then if you think along the
same line you'll see the move g6
and i just don't see any more squares on
that diagonal where the queen can defend
e2 i think we can go for that line check
and now very important move f5 okay
queen takes d4 is easy
but the point is that of queen h5 we go
g6
and the queen can no longer uh
defend the e2 square which basically
leads to checkmate
all right
next problem
ooh this is an interesting one
so we're down a queen for a rook and a
piece and i guess also a pawn
but you should immediately notice the
bishop on h6 which is uh ideally placed
and
clearly black once again has a back rank
weakness
and when i when i say background
weakness i don't necessarily mean that
black has pawns on f7 g7 and h7 this is
also this also qualifies as a background
weakness because white's controlling the
g7 square so if we got a rook to d8 or
e8 it would be mate
now immediately the move rookie 1 comes
to mind what happens there well if we go
rookie one
um i think black and whoops no not rook
c7 but i can drop the rook back to ca
um so it's not for black can also go f5
and create some luft for the king so we
it seems we have to play in a more
forcing manner
so the question is can we somehow
attack black's pieces
and you know one situation we could try
to aim for is one where we skewer the
queen and if the queen moves then we
have
a back rank mate now can we orchestrate
that well to do that we'll need to get
rid of the rook so the move rook c1
comes to mind so what happens after rook
c1
okay so the bishop guards the rook
so black can't take the rook black has
to move the queen to one of these
squares
then
we trade on c3 we get the queen to c3
and then we can bring the other rook to
c1
and i don't see a way in that position
that black can move his queen
and simultaneously guard the c8 square
because h3 is protected by our pawn
now which rook should we put on c1 well
that's important
i feel like if we put
this rock on c1 the f rook what black
can do is go queen f5
and keep contact with the other rook so
if we take on c3 there black takes on b1
and then returns to f5 and he's going to
be guarding the c8 square at the end so
it has to be rook bc1 and attention to
detail is very important when you're
solving
uh you know just trying to ask yourself
questions and if you ask yourself the
question in the right way you'll always
be able to answer right okay which rook
do i put on c1 well there is going to be
a difference you know that because
there's only one solution
um and and it's good to be able to to
detect those differences takes rook c1
check checkmate easy enough once we spot
the idea so this is the pivotal position
the black queen cannot move anywhere
to guard the c8 square
moving on ooh well this one's easy
if if you've solved you know a good
amount of you know beginner level
puzzles on mating patterns then you
should see this one pretty quickly uh
this
kind of general construction
is really asking for an arabian mate and
an arabian mate
is one where the knight and the rook
combine
to checkmate the black king in the
corner so an arabian-made construction
would happen after knight f6 and rook h7
or knight f6 and rook g8 a lot of people
here would just instantly play knight f6
unfortunately that move's not a check
you always have to pay attention to the
status of your own king even in an end
game and if you do that you'll see that
white's king is essentially out of
squares
and black is threatening checkmate and
one rook c1 is just mate
so
if we want to deliver an arabian mate we
have to do it by force so the idea that
comes to mind is can we can we uh
deflect black's king onto one of these
two squares and then bring the knight to
f6 with check we'll need to sacrifice a
rook to do that which rook do we
sacrifice well if we sack this rook then
the king takes and then if we go knight
f6 unfortunately we drop the other rook
if this rook was on
b7 that would be valid what about the
other way rook h7 check okay there the
king takes on h7
then we go knight f6 check and that
works out the king has to drop back and
then we deliver the arabian mates check
check
checkmate
oh all right
so
we have another end game
where
white has irish white is tripled pawns
on the f-file i call them irish pawns
for
reasons i will
eventually reveal and technically i
guess white is up two pawns
ah they're not the greatest pawns
uh what else do i see well i see the
x-ray
uh that the bishop is
exerting on white's king which means
there's a potential discovery with the
knight the other thing that i see here
is a standoff between the two rooks and
anytime there's a standoff combined with
the discovered
check you have to think in the direction
of using the discovery to slice off
the connection between
one of your opponent's pieces and the
piece that's involved in the standoff so
here the bishop on e4 is guarding the
rook now the longer the distance
physically between two pieces that are
guarding each other such as the queen or
in the rook or the bishop and the rook
the greater
uh the likelihood that something is
going to occur on the squares between
those two pieces right so if white's
bishop is on c2 that's a far safer
construction than a situation where
white's bishop is on e4 that's not
necessarily
something people think of intuitively so
can we use the discovery
uh to cover one of these two squares
well we absolutely can we can play
knight d3 check
we can play an id3 check
and then once the king steps aside
uh we take the rook on b1
and we're up in exchange but that's not
the end of the story because if you keep
following that line white's gonna take
our knight on d3 and remember why does
two pawns for the exchange so we need to
keep calculating there
now if you look carefully both of the
bishops in that ensuing position so once
again that's check
hear
takes takes both of the bishops are
undefended which if you've done a good
amount of chess.com puzzles you know
that they often end in a rook
forking two bishops
and so if you think in that direction
then i see the move rook b3 hitting the
bishop and if the bishop captures the
pawn we capture on c3 and both of
white's bishops in the end are hanging
and the scary thing about forking two
bishops is that they cannot defend each
other because they're on different
colored squares but that rook b3 move in
the end is very important so check
takes you can't stop here
because white's attacking the rook and
white's attacking c5
and white technically has enough
material for the exchange so this is a
very important move notice that the
bishop is trapped i mean if the bishop
drops back to c1 we take on c3 with the
exact same effect
okay we should be five we take
and we just start mopping up
uh the rest of the pieces very good
let's continue
oh this one's very nice actually
uh so
another end game we've got
a lot of stuff going on here
we have a pass pawn that's very far
advanced but it's currently being
restrained by the bishop
um and i think the mistake a lot of
people would make here is they would
immediately start thinking about
promoting the pawn can i promote the
pawn and then you'd be thinking well can
i get white's bishop off of c3 but you
don't have the enough pieces to do that
just because you only have two or three
pieces left doesn't mean you have to
stop thinking about checkmate you should
never stop thinking about checkmate you
should always hunt for
mating patterns especially when
uh especially when you've got incredibly
active pieces in when your opponent's
king is pushed back to the first string
because there's physically less real
estate you know the king just has two
squares
okay so the first move that comes to
mind is bishop b3 check that's a pretty
obvious candidate move let's see where
that leads
okay so king e1 is forced
and then i see another check sorry i see
another check with this bishop we can go
bishop f2 is that mate no it's
definitely not mate the king can step
back to d2
and it seems like we haven't made
uh it seems like we haven't made good
progress there
um because we've
you know it's actually quite
counterproductive
so let's go back to the position after
bishop e3 check king e1 i've noticed
something interesting which is that
after bishop f2 check if the king had to
go to f1
that's an incredibly vulnerable position
to be in and the king will be on a light
square so that bishop on b3
could potentially be used as the
checkmating piece
so what comes to mind after bishop b3
king e1 we need to somehow prevent the
white king from getting access to the d2
square well what if we push that pawn
and give it away bishop has to take it
otherwise we promote but wait a second
then we go bishop f2 check
now the king has to go to f1 and what's
more we can return to c4 with our light
squared bishop and that is simply
checkmate that's a beautiful mating
construction with two bishops so boom
and i think there's a name for this when
you essentially push upon or sacrifice a
piece to cover up one of your opponent's
escape squares uh it's a pretty typical
tactical motif so boom
boom
boom
and
we got it look at that mate beautiful
next position
okay so this is going to be clearly one
where we're just sort of trying to
attack
um
okay material is equal there doesn't
seem to be too much going on our rook is
currently hanging
what else can i say about this position
well it seems that black's king is quite
weak we have this bishop on d4 that's
x-raying the king i'm pretty obsessed
with x-rays because they're almost
always going to be important
uh and the other thing that i noticed is
just that these two pawns are incredibly
powerful if we get to push e6 that looks
completely overwhelming but if we delve
a little deeper i think i see what the
problem is because
if we move our rook just about anywhere
black's going to grab
the pawn on f5 and destroy our
destroyer pawn failings which is not
something we want to allow
uh so so
can we put our rook anywhere to defend
this pawn well not really i mean we can
go rick f4 but then the bishop is just
going to take the rook and it's even
worse
so the mover h4 comes to mind maybe we
can pin the bishop and make something
happen there rook h4
rook takes f5 now i mentioned earlier
the x-ray against black's king
and it's not enough to just notice stuff
you also have to figure out well in
under what circumstances can that be
exploited to your advantage how does
this x-ray work well in order to exploit
the x-ray we'll have to push the e-pawn
at some point right so let's consider
rook h4 rook takes f5 e6
that threatens rook takes h6 check
because of the pin the pawn cannot take
the rook unfortunately e6 is not a check
so here
here here is not a check
black has plenty of time black can even
move the king aside to g8
eliminating
any problems with rook takes h6
but in these situations you always want
to check what happens if you switch the
move order if you have two moves that
you're trying to make in this case it's
e6 followed by rook takes h6
automatic question what happens if i
make the second move first what happens
if you take the bishop first well if you
take the bishop first
black kinda has to take
then you push the pawn to e6 and
something i said earlier is very
important notice that the connection
between the queen and the rook occupies
four squares if you put something in
between that rook on f5 is going to be
left without a defender which is exactly
what happens rock h4
rook takes h6 and e6 severs the
connection between the queen of the rook
and then we can simply pick up
blackstroke
and at the end we're just up a piece
good
okay
oh this is a pretty i've had this one
before um
this one so again first thing i see is
is tremendous pressure on black's knife
it's being pressured by two different
pieces it's pinned
and uh whenever there's a pin piece pin
pieces that are not protected by pawns
are in significantly greater trouble uh
because you know they're a lot more
tenuous
so first of all what happens let's get a
sense of what's what's going on here if
we just take on f6 well black's gonna
take back
and i'm not really seeing where that's
going right i mean we can trade
everything on f6 and then maybe we can
take the h6 pawn but i'm not convinced
right that doesn't threaten anything
uh the solution to a chess.com puzzle is
always going to be more convincing than
just like oh you know you equal material
and you've got an open-ended attack
so
we'll have to involve some other factor
uh in this position
what else do i notice well i've noticed
the bishop on a2 x string the pawn on f7
but that doesn't mean just because you
notice something doesn't mean it's
necessarily going to be applied the
other thing that i see is the fact that
the white rook has
the open file and open files can be very
scary in conjunction with things like
pins
and
just me saying that should already kind
of make you see the solution
what we can do is we can play bishop
takes f6
and then we can use the rook as a decoy
we can play rook e8 check
for king the queen and the king that
forces the queen to take and then our
knight from d5 takes that bishop on f6
which is now a fork against black's
queen which is of course now on e8 how
did i see that well that's a pattern
that you should notice any time there's
a knight on d5 like this and you know
there's a possibility of that knight
jumping somewhere
uh
you know and your opponent's queen is in
the vicinity you have to look at ways
that you can use your other pieces uh to
deflect the queen onto a forkable square
that's just something you've got to sort
of check for
so bishop takes f6 of course not you
can't do the same thing with knight
takes up because then you won't have a
knight to fork with boom and you also
can't go rookie eight first
because if you go rookie 8 and then
bishop takes f6 black is under no
obligation uh to take on f6 black and
just ignore
and and then we're not going to have
anything to show for it so takes takes
check
takes on f6 and then we win the queen
okay let's uh do
two more let's do up to 10 problems
uh and then we'll we'll stop
so this is going to be clearly one where
we try to checkmate white's king it's on
h3 it's almost out of squares
uh and we're also down a rook so i just
don't see this happening any other way
we can give a perpetual here notice that
you can play queen g4 and then after
king g2 you can go back to e2 with the
queen
uh but let's look for more are there any
other checks in this position yes there
are there's queen f1
is that made well it's not made because
the bishop can drop back to g2 but one
thing a lot of people struggle with in
the realm of visualization is it's very
easy to forget that when a piece moves
away from a square
a square that it was previously
defending is now of course undefended it
sounds simple when i say it but when
you're calculating a longer line try to
make sure that you're not
uh seeing phantom pieces that you're
really really making sure to notice okay
the bishop has moved away from e4 so
whatever squares it was defending there
it's no longer defending and one of
those squares is f5 we can go queen back
to f5 and that's just checkmate g4 queen
takes g4 and that's easy enough boom
boom
boom
all right last one
another one where there's quite a bit
going on this is sort of a early middle
game
and my eyes are just drawn to like this
like there's a lot there there's also a
pin by the way that's just important to
point out but the the pawn on b2 is
guarding the knight so the pin doesn't
seem to be uh the reason that we're
going to win this game
uh
the x-ray though the rook x-raying the
bishop that seems to be a lot scarier
for white
uh because the bishop is only guarded by
the queen and in previous videos i've
talked about type one and type two
undefended pieces
uh i'll do a
video in the future where i lay out all
of that terminology but basically a type
2 undefended piece is a piece that is
only guarded by exactly one other piece
the bishop is only guarded by the queen
the queen is not a very good defender
because it's very easy to attack
so the first thing that comes to mind to
me
is well knight takes e5 right let's
let's try to take that knight and then
maybe take the bishop and then maybe we
can
we can force the queen onto f5 and then
we're gonna have a potential discovery
right so knight takes e5
okay probably white has to take back
then we take the bishop
then the queen takes and in that
position is there anywhere appealing
that we can put our knight well there is
right and this is where initial
observation is very important i said
this pin is not very dangerous well i
didn't know that yet and the move knight
e4 comes to mind in that position
hitting the queen and when the queen
moves we can just take the knight on c3
and if white recaptures we recapture
with our bishop and we give a fork to
the king and the rook so i think it's
knight takes e5 bishop takes e4
and boom
boom you can very clearly see how these
tactics are composed of individual
elements that you can detect and you can
observe and you can put them together
uh so you know and the more you solve
you know the better you become at
identifying factors in the position that
may play a role tactically but i can't
stress this enough
just because you've made a comprehensive
set of observations doesn't mean you're
automatically going to see the tactic
you have to
fulfill that inter you know that
intermediate step or okay you make
observations and then you actually look
at moves okay how can i exploit this how
can i try to explain that and it's also
important to realize that not everything
in every position can always be
exploited
uh you know and you shouldn't assume
that it can be
so
that was 10 intermediate level problems
that took us about uh 20 25 minutes i
think that's a perfect place to stop i
will definitely be making more of these
videos
uh in the future on uh beginner more
beginner problems and master level
problems i hope you enjoyed the video as
always feel free to leave questions in
the comments and i will see you very
soon in the next video thank you
[Music]